[موسيقى]
حتى عام 1902 تقريبًا ،
تضمنت المواد الحافظة للأغذية القانونية مواد كيميائية مثل
الفورمالديهايد البورق وكبريتات النحاس
حتى قام شخص واحد بتنظيم
نادي عشاء للسموم لإيقافه وأصبح
والد إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) ،
حسنًا ، إليك القصة من أجل الحفاظ على
مظهر
الطعام طازجًا  استخدم عددًا كبيرًا من
المواد الكيميائية
كبريتات النحاس ، وهو مبيد حشري شائع مصنوع من
البازلاء المعلبة
والبوراكس الأخضر اللامع والفورمالديهايد معبأ
باللحوم لجعله يبدو أكثر نضارة
في هذا الوقت من تاريخنا ، لم تكن
هناك لوائح غذائية حقيقية
لم تكن بحاجة إلى تصنيف المكونات الخاصة بك.
لا يوجد اختبار للسلامة
ولا
مراقبة ، دكتور
هارفي وايلي كيميائي لديه
فكرة مجنونة أن هذه المواد الكيميائية
ليس لها مكان في طعامنا ، بدأ بعض
التجارب المعملية الصحية حيث يمكنه
اختبار آثار هذه السموم على الجسم
رسميًا ، كان من السهل الحصول على  المواد الكيميائية لكنه
احتاج إلى
الجثث وهنا جاءت فرقة السموم
في أول 12 فردًا من فرقة السموم
متطوعين من ديبا  rtment
وتطوعوا لأكل
طعامه السام
لمدة ستة أشهر حتى يتمكن من تتبع
آثاره عليهم
كل يوم ستتغير القوائم
ولم يعرف متطوعو ويلي مطلقًا أي سم كانوا
يتناولونه
[موسيقى]
عشاء في نادي العشاء السام  قد
يبدو مثل هذا
عصير التفاح ، حساء الديك الرومي المعلب ،
لحم البقر ، البطاطا الحلوة ، البطاطا البيضاء ،
شرائح اللحم ، الخبز ، الزبدة ، القهوة
، بودنغ الأرز ، القليل من البورق
[الموسيقى]
خلال التجارب ، لاحظ ويلي علامات
التسمم الحاد
بما في ذلك اضطراب المعدة ، والغثيان ، والإسهال ،
والتقيؤ ، والأضرار الكلوية
التي تعرفها  يحدث عندما تتعرض
للتسمم
ولم يظل هذا مخفيًا ، حيث
اشتعلت الصحافة ، وفي عام 1906
تم تمرير اللوائح الغذائية الأولى ،
مما أدى في النهاية إلى إنشاء إدارة
الأغذية والعقاقير ، لذا شكرًا دكتور ويلي ، إن طعامنا أفضل بكثير
بدون كل هذا البورق
[موسيقى]
أنت